I mean obviously this isn't a realistic
penis it could be when I didn't know
about condoms I put in on the wrong way
didn't you have sex ed no I ain't pay
attention I was a class clown of the
condom okay attention
okay what's an expensive problem like is
it made of gold
condoms are amazing they're life-saving
if you don't got one make sure you get
Vera tasted like a flavored condom yeah
it has like a certain flexibility to it
I don't know why I'm doing this like you
could roll it on real nice and it stays
and you know you're safe Oh more hands
so that's what we're doing we're putting
these on the fruit it is slamming all
right pinch the reserve oh yes you're
right you don't even know let's see that
[ __ ] she never put it she go into the
same [ __ ] that I went through go ahead
yeah yeah the lube is already gone you'd
have to like use like a half bottle of
Lube after pinching the reserve oh I
broke it
okay well this is shitty condo see you
to put the condom on I'm like a child
with this we didn't even give him a fair
shot yeah we just put him on a papaya
so good luck my friend oh wow no this
might be pretty
I mean Duty oh this one is so Looby oh
no I have a weird feeling that's
probably expensive one what is this like
most like chai tea latte
Organic but only of cage-free yeah
cruelty-free some organic condoms that
liked it what is it the deteriorates
into the earth your Baha I'm not
actually that's the last thing you want
oh very nice nice slide very nice glide
we have going on here I would say this
one's the cheapest medium price I would
say that time and this was the most
expensive one
I agree agree I mean and if it we're not
right then yo check your condom prices
it was too late to me I'm gonna go ahead
and say this to some hipster shits of
this I want to say it's like Whole Foods
so it's expensive at least we knew that
we were completely wrong yeah points for
that
what's expensive haha that's right
that's right that's right that's right
why is this the most especially always
lunch that's why it smells so bad how
he's supposed to feel better
that's a lamb skin to me this one got
the job done I would definitely go with
this guy seems like fair good condom
invisible ultra thin this is like
triggering me and I'm gonna need to
editor get laid tonight or something
[Music]